wie viel schuld trägt frau von der leyen
das kann ich ihnen dann erst sagen wenn
ich die gesperrten unterlagen wirklich
ein klarer so haben meines erachtens
steht aufgrund der informationen die wir
stand heute haben fest sie hat mit der
kommission zu lange um den letzten cent
gefallen statt vorne heraus ausreichend
und schneller zugestellt
ganz konkret die frage aus ihrer sicht
wie lange ist von der leyen als
kommissionschef in der noch tragbar sie
sprachen ja auch die erfahrung im
verteidigungsministerium an und auch da
gab es ja deutliche kritik von ihnen
wenn sie weiter derartig mauert und den
prozess nach vorne nicht schleunigst
dann wird es nur noch eine sehr kurze
zeit seien sie sagen eine sehr kurze
zeit sein wie kommen sie darauf weil
auch sozusagen in der union also in der
svp kritikern aufkommt ja weil jetzt
letztendlich insgesamt unmut da ist und
auch das europäische parlament fordert
dass es auf augenhöhe informiert wird
wie erfahren das meiste momentan aus der
zeitung das kann so nicht weitergehen
aber letztendlich sehen wir momentan
auch noch keinen ansatz dass sich die
situation verbessert
gleichwohl sie hat jetzt die chance die
haben sie aufgefordert im parlament rede
und antwort zu stellen ich bin gespannt
ob das mehr als nur eine werbemaßnahme
wird und dann wird man beurteilen müssen
wie sie sich den prozess nach vorne
hinaus vorstellen wir müssen jetzt
schneller werden das sind wir den
menschen schulen